hey guys in this video we're going to
take a look at what the Bible says about
how men should dress and how they should
take care of their appearance
now I know some of you might be thinking
Daniel the Bible doesn't say anything
about this
well you're wrong the Bible has a lot to
say about how we present ourselves to
the world which will become clear in
this video
and this will shock many of you because
preachers never talk about it or at
least I haven't heard a preacher talk
about this in my whole life
now you need to know that you can be a
stumbling block to an unbeliever
pushing them away from the gospel just
because of your appearance
yeah let me explain there are too many
Christian men look sloppy unprofessional
lazy
and who don't care about their
appearance at all you know it is great
that God is not like man not like human
beings because he doesn't judge based on
our outside appearance what will look
like you know we always say this don't
judge a book by its cover but we do this
we humans because we are not perfect we
are not God God now he looks at your
heart your intentions your character and
that's how he judges you
but we missed the part where the Bible
also says that men judge according to
the outside appearance because they
can't see right through you they're not
God
one Samuel 16 verse 7 for the Lord sees
not as man sees man looks on the outward
appearance
but the Lord looks on the heart now most
of the time when people read this they
just focus on the part where it says
that God judges the heart but they
totally just live out the part that says
that man focuses on the outside
appearance and this is important for us
to understand I'm going to explain to
you why I'm mentioning this a little bit
later on but first I need to make this
very clear
because I don't want you to
misunderstand the point I'm trying to
make vanity is a sin
and it is a lot more important to focus
on the inside than on the outside
spiritual growth that's a lot more
important than just focusing on your
outside appearance
which will just return to dust anyway
Genesis 3 verse 19 for you are dust and
to dust you shall return
so let me ask you if you are God's
Ambassador living in his Temple your
body and people look at you
when you represent God what do they see
their first impressions
someone who looks modest
who looks respectful
or someone who dresses in a way that is
flashy and attention seeking someone who
professes to be a Christian but is so
self-absorbed that they don't realize
they're worshiping themselves instead of
God
so I want to be very clear on this
dressing to impress for the wrong
reasons
being vain aiming to be the guy who
always wants the best and most costly
expensive Brands because of vanity is
wrong or if you do it because you think
it approves your self-worth it is wrong
because your self-worth is only found in
God
vanity makes you
self-absorbed arrogant
puffed up and selfish and can lead to
Envy strife and well an empty and sad
life
Proverbs 16 Verse 18 says Pride goes
before destruction and a hearty spirit
before a fall
now what I'm talking about in this video
is all the way to the other side The
Other Extreme Men Christian men
who think that they shouldn't take care
of their appearance at all so they don't
groom they don't look modest they don't
look respectful for example if you want
to share the gospel to someone you're
walking towards them they see you they
already start to make judgments on you
based on your appearance
man this guy who looks sloppy it doesn't
look respectful at all it doesn't look
modest I I don't want anything to do
with him so they already decide there
and then that they don't want to listen
to you so how are you going to share the
gospel to them if they are already
negative towards you nowhere in
scripture does it say that you should
not take care of your appearance
it does say that your character is more
important and we all know that but it
also says a great deal about how you
present yourself to other people I mean
you are
God's ambassador
Paul says in one Corinthians 9 verse 20
to the Jews I became as a Jew in order
to win Jews to those under the law I
became as one under the law though not
being myself under the law that I might
win those under the law verse 21 to
those outside the law I became as one
outside the law not being outside the
law of God but under the law of Christ
that I might win those outside the law
to the weak I became weak that I might
win the week now listen to this
I have become all things to all people
that by all means I might save some
you can't dress sloppy and go to talk to
someone who is very worldly and thinks
about the importance of appearance all
the time who's so self-absorbed that
just wants to wear designer Brands all
the time they they probably wouldn't
even want to start listening to you and
you can't dress in a nice suit to talk
to a homeless person
you gotta think yes it is sad but this
is the world that we live in all humans
not one is perfect and so people make
assumptions based on the appearance of
other people people have sinful natures
and those sinful Natures will judge you
wrongly
so dress according to the occasion in
order to save Souls don't always just
dress like a church person
but dress more in line with those who
are trying to save if you don't connect
with people on their level then you'll
be an obstacle for them to hear the
gospel
and you have to do it
as you do everything now because we're
under the law of the spirit which means
everything you do know should be through
the spirit meaning everything you do
should be done for God
even normal things like eating and
drinking
for example 1 Corinthians 10 31 says
whether you eat or drink or whatever you
do do all to the glory of God
now some of you might say oh come on
Daniel something as basic as food and
drink how do we do that for God or first
of all it's not me who says it it's
God's word that says this and when we
look at something as basic as food and
drink
you need to ask yourself
how much food do I eat
am I addicted to food a glutton or am I
so worried about my appearance that I
don't eat enough to live healthy and do
I pray before I eat and thank God for
the food that he's given me so yes even
in the food and drink that we consume we
have to honor God
and that goes for everything you do
everything must be done through the
spirit and that includes taking care of
your appearance
some of you might still be asking good
Daniel what does this have to do with my
appearance what is my faith
what does that have to do with my
appearance
everything
your appearance is a reflection of your
inner character a new creation
that is different from the person you
used to be now you dress in a way that
is modest respectful and you are showing
the world that you are a man of Faith so
we should take care of our appearance we
should groom ourselves properly
and keep ourselves clean hygienic
healthy
you should also dress more respectable
so that other people will feel more
inclined to go and talk to you
especially if you want to share the
gospel to them they want to feel man I
feel that I could just go and talk to
this person this this person feels warm
open modest respectable
there's something about this person
1 Timothy 2 verse 9 women should Adorn
themselves in respectable apparel who
have modesty and self-control not with
braided hair and gold or pearls or
costly attire but with what is proper
for women who profess godliness with
good works
did you see that your appearance that
goes together with your good works
that is what you are showing to the
world now I know Paul wrote this to
women right but does it not apply to men
as well
today men can also dress in a way that
does not honor God
and the Greek word here used for modesty
is cosmos
and the same word is used when you talk
to men in 1 Timothy 3 verse 2 therefore
an overseer must be above reproach the
husband of one wife sober minded
self-control and here it comes listen up
respectable hospitable able to teach so
your appearance is important dressing
modestly is for men and women
the Bible even talks about bodily
training one Timothy 4 8.
for wild bodily training is of some
value
godliness is of value in every way
yes and no training in godliness growing
spiritually you know really connecting
to God God sees your heart that is a lot
more important than what's going on on
your outside appearance but
you cannot live selfishly oh it's just
me and my relationship with God what
about other people you are called to
share the gospel so to do that you
cannot be a stumbling block for other
people you need to connect with them at
their level
and even though
spiritual growth is important more
important than bodily training it
doesn't say here that bodily training is
not important it says that it is of some
value
now some of you might be thinking wow
did they train their bodies in the time
of the Bible yes don't think you're
something special because you live 2000
years later there's nothing new Under
the Sun they also had athletes
1 Corinthians 9 verse 25 every athlete
exercises self-control in all things
now how can you be the light of the
world a sweet smelling Aroma lived
peaceably with old people if people
don't even want to talk to you because
you don't use deodorant
you smell and you don't groom you look
like someone who's lazy not respectable
at all no you need to be the light of
the world they need to be able to think
man this this person there's something
about this person I want to I want to
get to know this person
who are they what are they thinking they
look like someone who's modest
respectable
Jesus says in Matthew 5 14 you are the
light of the world a city set on a hill
can not be hidden
now of course like I said shining your
light goes hand in hand with your
actions so your appearance and your
actions the example that you set to
non-believers all those things work
together and of course you cannot do it
if you don't share the gospel through
the power of the holy spirit because it
is not us who are changing lives it is
Jesus Christ and only he can do that
through people who are preaching through
the holy spirit so don't do it through
the flesh
and next time when you prepare yourself
in the morning you're getting ready
you're getting groomed remember to dress
according to the occasion work on your
appearance
in such a way that is modest respectful
and also appropriate
now if you want more videos more advice
for men then please watch these videos
here and I'll see you there
and always remember life is short so
don't waste yours bye guys